okay Alicia Alicia where you from
originally I'm from Houston Texas seven
to eight once yes the things that I was
going through at home staying with my
mother all the way from being a child
all the ways still up until being adult
but things that she keep attending and
looking at the way this will be allowing
allowing to happen not to me I come
first husband he kept he took Melissa me
as a child as he knew she knew he was
doing it and wouldn't say nothing he
knew he was coming in my room
she never stopping see it's like looking
the other way
I'm pretending like this it's not
happening and I'm I'm her oldest child
I'm I'm the firstborn my mother is
supposed to protect a shop
when eight years old right to this day
the one that she married he's not my
real father
but he's my other sister brothers father
so my sisters I had let him know what
was happening because I didn't want the
same thing to happen to him I me being
the oldest and trying to be like a a big
brother by protecting them and my two
brothers they were the last to be born I
didn't ever share it with them because I
didn't want them to change I didn't feel
too good as a father because I knew how
much they loved him but then when he
when he got over his CB he and I already
had sex in life gave his life to God he
had asked me to forgive him for the
things that he had done to me instead
that I had been protecting him all these
years
but my mother that's a skeleton in her
closet see let me grow up I'm the only
one in our family ever be known in jail
or smoked cigarettes or drink or drugs
the rest of my siblings are totally the
opposite it's like being the black sheep
of the family and my mother she she
belittles me see does verbal abuse to me
all the time this this he remarried
another guy who's ten years younger than
her ten years younger than her and my
mom and him put me out some time I will
come to life my mother and I said could
I get a couple of hours of sleep there
at the house and then we're not
heed my mom and him because he asked me
could he help both of us
and that's something uh this she gives
him anything he's on every day my mother
is the bread my stepfather he gets money
but she lets him do whatever he wants to
do with his money when I woke up the man
was there my mom sleeps in the front
living room he won't even let my mom
sleep in a bed with him she sleeps in
the front living room and she has her
own bedroom and see on the couch she's
playing sleep cuz whenever he's on any
type of controlled substance
she's not gonna never go to sleep she
won't stay up and watch him because you
feel like he's dangerous there but she
laid on that couch and I laid on the
ground the couch across from her it was
like deja vu all over again
hmm when I woke up this man was laying
butt-naked on his back on the floor
taking my hand and from there with his
dick with my mom older but the couch
across from me while she laid there and
play like she was sleeping I felt like I
felt
all over again then one time I mom let
me come now and go to sleep and she told
me he goes go get help you can go to
sleep and what made me wake up here them
came in here that came in my mom's room
and got in the bed with me naked and so
I came running out of my mother's room
out of her bed and curled up like in the
fetus position on the floor on the side
of my mom and when he did wake up he
came on my mom's room and he had her oh
the girls that come to the thigh the pay
the girls come here he didn't wanted him
they looked like biking shots on him but
they wasn't it was my mom's girdle and
si si si yeah she never did teach me
about ministration boys six Oh cook I
never will understand that mm-hmm
she don't put me in every rehab there is
in Houston Texas she didn't miss Warren
what's the angle I see never could
understand she never attended any type
of family meeting group mean to educate
herself why I fell in the condition that
I was in when I did get started doing
drugs I grabbed onto the log because I
stayed on the street for eight years
eight years as a whole a prostitute oh
don't be giving my body up for two
dollars studying dicks for a hit of dope
give me my family heard they were
soulless a mummy it's like they had
totally distant they self and I didn't
associate with him because I felt like I
was an embarrassment embarrassment to
them by me being the oldest I'm sold one
day I said I had don't try to draw
I decided not alone I started getting
the habit of practicing making it part
of my routine every day to read the
Bible in the morning and they need to
naturally the instructions in the Bible
so I helped me to change my life I
stayed clean for 14 years until I
realized I wasn't going around people
who doing drugs you don't have to
relapse by going back to the old
neighborhood just just being a unhappy
you can have everything you want the
Lord was blessing me when he said he is
your Shepherd she said no I didn't know
what nothing I just didn't have a man in
my life and when I did I wanted to come
in my life I fell in love with with the
way he was with the way he was look at
me
I've always never been old-fashioned and
teaching and he was ungodly
I fell in love with him hmm I love this
man took a beat me all the time with
anything he'd get his hands on me I
thought that was love I loved him so
much time wanted a child for this man I
ended up having a child that's me this
man beating me through my whole nine
months of pregnancy eventually this man
ended up going to jail that I had my
baby I had my child and he got popped
because he was a dope Dylan I was a hope
beyond hope
give him earrings for money and dope but
he got popular with the jail I was son
with seven months old why he's in jail
life and made up my mind it changed my
life because the baby had made a
difference in my life to have the baby
it made a difference in my life he's my
only child I had to be the mother in and
daddy I never did get on any type of
food stamps I know they get on any type
of government assistance I didn't put
child support him on your mind anything
when I was the mother and dad to my son
when I when he came out our son was six
years old he left when he was seven
months old I had gone fully in my life
on the way I was going to college
full-time at University of Houston my
major was criminal justice I was running
full time for him there Mars candy
they make Snickers three musketeers
Milky Way skittles and stubborn I don't
save my money up and I bought meat I had
don't bought me a house yeah me a house
I had all the fields that America where
every right whatever year was that's
what year my ride was let me tell you
something about the Lord every time I
wanted me something brand new he didn't
get it let me get it out the parking lot
he let mommy him to come off the
showroom floor
I had him so cool in my life he was
overflowing my bless my cup with
blessings for me to be able to work
full-time goes
to put her by the house brand-new truck
fishing amazing when I relapse at the
Linnet ungodly man I know what unequal
yoke is now when one of us is nothing to
the Lord and one of us is not I start
slacking up in everything that has
something to do with the Lord hate him
all the way in my life because I won the
title getting off the drugs and it had
beaten my body up for so many years you
couldn't get me to open my legs anymore
once I became gone nobody turn to me I
wanted no man come in my life outside my
being the oldest and tried to send an
example for my sisters and brothers I
allowed that man who I had a baby for to
come back in my life after he had been
gone all those years Towson was 6 years
old this is a man who did not have a
relationship with his own son yeah I
named my son after him he's a junior
mm-hmm well I became the bridge just
like how my mom is to Britt hit her
house I became to breathe I became to
bread before I even met him before he
even got out of jail because I had
brought the Lord all the way in my life
you hear me the Lord had blessed me with
a good job he had blessed me with his
strength for me a baby to work full-time
go to school full-time and raise a baby
by myself without any type of government
assistance for me to be buying a house
driving a new vehicle with no help from
family I know me you know I give all the
credit to the Lord you hear me I was
actually walking it I know what it's
like to be all the way down to when you
sit in a deep for hit and dump and
you've been somebody funky for two
dollars I know what it's like to be all
the way down there
you hear me and I know what it's like to
be all the way up there when it's all
about the Lord know when you got him
first every day in your life for 14
years now not the relapses I learned
from it cuz everything that the Lord
allowed you to go through he expect for
you to learn from me these are all
called
trials and tribulations and in the Bible
he tells you when you go through your
tribulations to be cheerful but I
learned from him too I learned about the
unequally yoked I learned about not
turning to the family to turn to a
stranger
I learned what happened if you slack up
and everything to help something to do
with the Lord you hear me you say it'll
be to god she's gonna live one and
despise the other
say neither God you hear me every
decision I always made it had to be
something that was pleasing to the Lord
for me not to make any wrong choices the
privilege that the Lord gave you is to
make your own choices well he gave you
that privilege don't nobody make you do
anything you can make a healthy choice
you can make a fucked-up choice one or
the other
if something ain't going right miss
cousin the choices that you make every
day that I choose to do but not the Lord
in my life now to the fullest ain't
nothing gonna go right from me it's
gonna take the Lord I call it a monkey I
got that monkey back on my back again be
back on my back and I know what I got to
do but the law say well how long you
gonna continue to suffer you hear me and
I see
so how long you gonna keep being foolish
and I said we show right Lord you shall
write because being out here in a state
that ain't got no family and they ain't
never been here and I'm experiencing
things I never dreamed that I could ever
experience being here in California some
of the stuff is just so overwhelming
here it's so overwhelming and so I just
break down it makes you talk to the Lord
yeah yeah make you talk to the Lord
because I don't have nobody but the Lord
here sometime I'm dialing some time I'm
back up here me and the only way I'm
gonna stay up there to continue to build
my relationship with the Lord
my stepfather I couldn't take a bath in
that house if my mama left to go to the
bank or something because this man we're
but see in that bathroom he does the
dough knob off the bathroom and it fix
my bedroom where would like no mo nah
but the only time I had to worry about
him attacking me but he was so
disrespectful in the things and my mom
knew he was doing this year Lau it's the
second man seeing alone um I'm somebody
who ain't never had counseling hmm
I wrote my life story one time and a
hundred pages of one of the rehabs my
mom knew this man was coming into my
room I could smell the alcohol on his
breath how do you climb on top of me she
didn't do nothing but when he get ready
to die I said her daddy don't make it
cuz I call him daddy daddy don't make it
I'm bringing that skeleton not the plug
because it had been in the closet was
nolo because it was nolo was he allowed
little bit what a mother no wasn't happy
to uh challenge Geodude
that's that's so terrible yeah I mean
that's a monster huh you don't even say
the word god unless you tell him you
ain't got God in me he tried to beat me
up with burr Bobby's still I know I
don't have to listen to somebody talk
with verbal news he actually does verbal
abuse
I call it jealous spirits you hear me
I'm hereford boy
it's got to be proud of me because I'm
the one who came out the drugs as a
stoned OFI and grunting I'm the only one
that has ever been to college my mom
made all my clothes everything I want to
screw every day my mom made it
when heard my dad was together she
didn't have to work but one day when we
came home from school my mom said pack
up everything and go so my dad came home
we was gone my mom never did tell us why
we moved while we was moving I didn't
even daddy but I knew it I knew it was
time she should have been pulling us out
of that house
well I don't know that her husband was
coming in my bedroom messing with me she
should have been done it he's gonna been
done something about it but goodness
watchin his daddy my brother's name
still don't know
the sisters are here only me I'm the
only one with a different father and
I'll arrest them have the same father
and I'll just have to say mother by my
mother not accepting responsibility of
teaching me the things that a mother
supposed to teach I made it my
responsibility to teach my sister now
all the things my mom need teachers
administration six boys cooking birth
control pills training bras and mites in
his day went with my niece Bobby I'm not
by my my hurting not teaching me and she
didn't teach my sister now nothing to my
system you know I could stay real with
let them know things that they needed to
know that's growing up in life and when
my system had girls when they got
pregnant and had girl babies gets one
when they grew up old enough I went to
the library and I went to film and I
showed that film about ministration that
day they showed you in school
I did my niece's the same way because I
felt like if my sister Nell didn't learn
from my mom that they might do they
girls like that tell them about things
they need to know anything girls
I did it with my nieces and nephews my
niece is near and far the nephews in my
my son I always taught my son that made
me didn't want to have no more kids hear
me say one time iTunes cuz I wish I was
30 something to have a baby I'm the
oldest and I was the last one to bring a
grandchild in the family the last one to
have a baby to be away from now there is
a relief to them
but if I was to ever grab back onto the
Lord I would be an ATM machine again
today yeah I hate him when you love a
family member I don't care what
condition that they fall in love all
didn't be good in a bag the Lord don't
change up none of us he just got his
hand out all day long to the disobedient
contrary people he forgive us for all
our sins and he remembers no more huh so
in order for me to grab back on the Lord
I came right back here I never been here
but the first time I grabbed on to the
Lord I love Texas in which a Louisiana
when I came back from Louisiana I was
untouchable it's like having on the fool
armored guard you featured 16 through 18
it's just full armor anything they're
trying to come against you
and my buddy and I'd stand up so often
to the Lord I feeling really loved the
Lord I didn't even want a man in my life
because the law was blessing me with
everything I wanted I didn't even need
no me then I start [ __ ] and me when
that man came back to being locked up
all of years I said I'm a settlement and
sending examples you try to raise my son
be with the father of my child not have
this daddy
and that daddy for this child is dead
daddy for that child cuz that's how they
are the only one that had one child in
his family and I'm the last one to have
a child
I tried their head I moved around it and
enjoyed my life before I had decided to
have a baby
I stayed in Atlanta Georgia five years
you know kids first time I have had a
drink of alcohol was and look Red
Lobster on my 21st birthday in Atlanta
Georgia a Long Island iced tea I just so
see I'd say to me a long time forehead
it would
a drink with some alcohol in it again
but that was my first it's crack crack
crack is my drill I call it the devil
love potion it's something that we put
in our body and our body is his temple
it's abomination to the Lord to use
great cocaine on any of those drugs
because all those drugs don't break
nothing positive in your life
he's tell us in Genesis he said go and
multiply be fruitful proof was
everything that's positive you hear me
yeah and the only way a person to say
they're happy you know be happier you
can only get happiness with the Lord God
is a jealous God you ain't gonna be
happy and don't serve Him he's not gonna
let it go like that I learnt it is all
about him it's all about him that's why
he said come to me for rest take my yoke
dumb instructions meaning instructions
are real to me strippers teaches us how
to deal with everything we're going
through on a daily basis with these
oppressor palaces witchcraft is evil
spirits that you can't even see me to
hide they around us yeah me and I'm
gonna grab back don't tell McGee when I
grab on to him I'm going back to Houston
and I'm open up your business it's gonna
be called northwest side wash it's here
I will put it in between both
neighborhoods well I did all my heart
all my drilling and all my stealing it
I'm gonna give back to both communities
because watch this here that they have
to go to and move them neighborhoods
that I did on it now I'll let messing up
my life here they have to get on a bus
and go so clean ride the bus
Oh quite a bit of ways just to get to
the lunch of man here to make money year
round and a prosper I will put a border
line right there by the elders he talked
about the elders in
and then you got the the projects the
village with the women and children
that's gonna help them they have a watch
the chair right up at the cone right
then cone and it's gonna be right there
in the neighborhood I'm again back to
the community that I did so much wrong
doing it so much it's why I changed my
life and did turn right back upside down
you hear me
turnt it right back upside down oh boy
it's a 1 here that may have brought that
crack in my house why would you break
something in my house they had me go
down for eight years
you got it every day he didn't I'm gonna
look on two cars got one to try to work
wanna drive on a week
he didn't make as much money as I did Oh
father Day and Mother's Day he might
give me a hundred and fifty Father's Day
see I'm gonna give you what I wanted him
I'm gonna give you $1,000 if you some
some rims that he'd been looking at for
his car and you told his best friend I'm
gonna go through his best friend nothing
to have all his friends I know I learned
how to cook take away Thanksgiving
Christmas in New Year's
everybody's gonna be in my house and my
house cuz I keep something tradition
then my grandmother kept up my mom and
my hunt they didn't they didn't do it
but all three holiday and didn't up for
would you like I'm gonna be in my dad's
house the one that was molesting me and
I'm gonna had a whole sky lit up I'm
gonna spend seven to eight hundred
dollars lighting up the whole sky people
free to pull up on the side of the road
cuz his house set on a half acre I said
way back huh cuz I forgave him I forgave
him I had to cuz if you don't forgive a
person the law would not forgive him
I had learned all that and not for the
Lord be blessing me with so many
blessing the strength I had to pay for
go to school full-time and work
full-time and raise up baby by myself
you hear me none not no daycare not my
mama me something keeping my child a
baby by myself
the Lord is o mighty he so almighty if
we just give him a chance I had to hit
rock bottom to learn it
thanks a lot for listening to me I'm
sorry freaking some emotion around I
appreciate it I'm not - I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna share with too many people
I really appreciate it it took a lot for
me mommy what I better start doing why
I'm here that's what you know it's like
I don't forgot what my purpose isn't
being here and to go through all those
steps with my life I say you must
forgotten are you if you're doing the
same thing again what you're doing the
Houston Texas you don't forgot what's
your real reason you just standing with
you reminded me with my real reason is
they're not thank you for that really
cool we took my breath away
because my breath away I know I I don't
know I think this one zero
oh no well you take my breath away
Oh
a new a new biting my breath awake I
never had anybody to take my breath away
took my breath away my breath away